I can't speak to it do we or do we not
have free will what I can say with some
confidence is there are things that we
can do to develop a Freer will Freer
than before and that might make all the
difference we can come to know ourselves
more fully fundamentally there are
things about ourselves and why we do
what we do that aren't fully under our
control
for the people who aren't familiar with
you what's your background who are you
what do you do
uh I'm a psychologist I'm a professor of
psychology at University of California
San Francisco
I practice psychoanalytic psychology
which for people who may not know is
based on the understanding that we don't
fully know ourselves that there's such a
thing as unconscious mental life and
that we can explore it and understand it
and be better for it what is unique
about that compared with other
approaches for psychology
yeah that's a good question
um there's been a trend so so first of
all I mean there's just just
mind-boggling psychological illiteracy
in the culture and and it's not the
fault of you know it it's not the fault
of anyone it's what they're teaching in
universities you know even even people
who you know even people who take
University level courses in Psychology
um are going to miss something really
important and the important thing is
that over the last
25 to 30 years
the entire field of psychotherapy has
really been getting very very shallow
and there's been there's been a focus on
increasingly brief increasingly
superficial and increasingly cheap
interventions and they get sold to the
public by academic researchers and I'm
not taking shots I am an academic
researcher I'm not I'm not trying to
trash anyone but they get sold to the
public as you know these are scientific
you know scientific forms of treatment
they're evidence-based they're the gold
standard but but actually they're
they've been getting increasingly
superficial and what I mean by
superficial is
there's an assumption that that it can
happen very quickly
that we can deal with what's on the
surface of Consciousness right so your
conscious beliefs and thoughts uh so the
focus is very much on
managing symptoms and dealing with
thoughts and behaviors that are very
much on the surface of things rather
than the underlying psychology that
gives rise to them and the entire
tradition that that I'm part of is is
based on the understanding that we don't
fully know our own hearts and Minds
nobody does it's the nature of The Human
Condition it's rooted in the structure
of the brain we don't fully know
ourselves and you know because we don't
fully know ourselves we find ourselves
repeating the same kinds of patterns and
getting in the same into the same kinds
of difficulties over and over again in
life and the idea is that by coming to
know the parts of ourselves that were
previously unknown that gives us some
freedom to be able to do things
differently so that we're not doomed to
repeating the same patterns over and
over given that we don't know ourselves
does that not provide a very difficult
challenge when it comes to trying to
uncover that if somebody doesn't know
how do you get to know
well I mean it's a matter of degree and
this entire approach to therapy is all
about you know how do we work in a way
that makes the unknown parts of
ourselves more known and and actually uh
uh you know probably the most
straightforward way to explain it is the
unknown parts of ourselves emerge in a
relationship it doesn't happen in a
vacuum right which is why all these
you know self-help programs and wellness
apps and you know online things are sort
of missed the point that the things
about ourselves that we don't know
are manifested in our relationships we
tend to repeat the same kinds of
relationship patterns over and over
again for better or worse
um
and
Psychotherapy meaningful Psychotherapy
is also a relationship so we tend to
bring our patterns and our templates for
relationships into the Psychotherapy
relationship and they get repeated there
and a therapist who really knows what
he's doing
that's not you know
um that's not a distraction from the
therapy that is the therapy it's because
we bring our patterns into the therapy
situation right that it becomes possible
to recognize them understand them and
hopefully to rework them right our Pat
when I say you know parts of ourselves
we don't know I mean our repetitive
relationship patterns have been there
from the very beginning they're formed
in our you know our earliest
relationships with caretakers and
because they've been there from the
beginning
you know they're as invisible to us as
water is to a fish right for us that's
just how it is so it's in the context of
a relationship where somebody else can
say
you know well wait a minute you know
you're assuming this you're doing that
perhaps there's another way to think
about this
so that's
kind of a
short quick answer you look you look
puzzled no I like it I like it very much
I um I mean I'm fascinated by human
nature and by the parts of us that we
don't understand and as far as I can see
it the only way to transcend your
programming is to become aware of it or
at least first you have to become aware
of it you have to become aware of it and
you have to become aware of it not in
some just you know cognitive or
intellectual sense you have to become
aware of it you know in a sort of deeper
emotional you know lived way that
actually makes a difference because you
know intellectual knowledge is kind of
cheap so when we say in Psycho in
psychoanalytic therapy we talk about
Insight you know we don't mean something
that somebody can just tell you or that
you can read in a book we need an
Insight that really you know sinks in at
a deep emotional level in a way that
leads you to do something different so I
would say it's it's lived in sight not
intellectual Insight so you had this
thread this is how I came across you did
this brilliant thread on Twitter which
broke down a bunch of psychoanalytical
Concepts and ideas some of them people
are probably going to be familiar with
and some will be new to them but the
reason that I really liked it was it
identified to me where I had me
understood some ideas that I thought I
had a really good grasp on so I just
want you to go through a bunch of them
today okay and we can riff off some of
my favorite ones from that tweet thread
and for the people sounds good to make
the thread out I'll link that below and
they can go and check it out once we're
done so moral masochism leaving your
suffering makes you more important or
virtuous than others for example feeling
Superior to others based on your
self-deprivation or self-sacrifice
what's that
um so this is a very interesting concept
we we all do things we have to do things
to try to find a way to to feel good
about ourselves you know to feel like
we're you know we're good people
other people like us other people care
about us you know we're a good human
being and
um but moral masochism is is something
really specific where somehow the
person's self-esteem gets tied up with
how much self-renunciation or
self-suffering they endure right so the
idea is
um I'm a better person than you because
I suffer more I'm more morally virtuous
than you you know because uh you know
because I'm a victim I'm more morally
virtuous than you because I uh you know
I deprive myself of more give up more
it's kind of we could say kind of the
Martyr complex right and and it's very
difficult to treat in Psychotherapy that
usually people cut you know nobody comes
in and says I'm here for I'm here
because I struggle with moral masochism
that that has just never happened in the
history of the world usually when
somebody like this comes to therapy
the way they experienced it as as
depression you know they're they're you
know they're they're down they're
listless you know they've lost their
enthusiasm for Life they're you know
they're despondent
and normally when you treat depression
and Psychotherapy
there's a there's an improvement you
know fairly quickly at least initially
that it comes about just by virtue of
being in a relationship with a person
can be you know heard deeply you know
listen to understood where there's an
expectation of help right there's
there's usually a fairly quick shift at
least you know at least at the start and
what happens when you see somebody where
moral masochism is prominent is
they don't respond positively to the
therapist's
sympathetic compassionate interest they
that it's it's unconscious but there's
an important way they don't want to feel
better because they're suffering and
their their self-deprivation and their
self-punitiveness is what makes them
feel like they're a better person and
you know and actually we see this we see
this in social media all the time I mean
you know you can get look at your
Twitter feed you know just just look for
five minutes and you'll find examples of
moral masochism where basically the
message being broadcast is that I'm
somehow morally Superior or morally more
virtuous than you
because I'm more deprived
right so then the person ends up it's
it's not just that they're deprived it's
they have a they really have a strong
psychological incentive to remain
deprived further the deprivation yeah
yeah because if they gave up the
deprivation
well then they're just a human being
like like the rest of us you know
they're not self-righteously virtuous or
morally Superior in any way they're just
you know just people it feels like
there's maybe two broad categories that
are contributing here one being
um what the world is doing to the person
uh I.E the world
um holds back from them or puts them
into a situation which causes them to
suffer and the other side of this is
what the person does to themselves it's
how they either continue to propagate or
cause in the first place and instigate
the issues yeah and the person who is
not
morally masochistic who is put by the
world you know circumstances social
conditions you know put in a position of
deprivation or suffering they will do
whatever they can do whatever they know
how to do to try to escape those
conditions right right it's not like
they see any particular virtue in it
it's like like this sucks like you know
how can I how can I you know find
something better for myself in the world
how can I find a better place for myself
you know where I'm not being so put upon
or so deprived whereas for somebody with
with moral masochism it's like you know
they'll complain bitterly about it but a
part of them is you know is really
really attached to the Suffering The
reveling in it almost there's a way that
they're reveling in it are these so just
for when we go through these concepts
are these all uh clinically diagnosable
or these are represented in the clinical
literature yes but but see all of these
things are matters of degree like these
aren't these aren't special you know
mysterious things that you know apply to
some Disturbed subset of the population
I mean these are things that apply to
humans to to varying degrees right every
I mean all the things we're going to
talk about today I mean every one of us
does some of these things you know some
of the time to some extent right it
becomes a problem when this becomes a
you know sort of dominant way of living
in the world yes so the moral masochism
thing my isolated when you first said
that
throughout most of my 20s I attached my
sense of self-worth to the business that
I ran which I don't think is too
uncommon you know you a young guy going
out into the world not really much of a
sense of self you find something that
you're good at and then you begin to
attach you to the performance of the
thing that you do I imagine the athletes
and and
um classical music players probably have
the same sort of thing they have a good
recital or a good practice or a good
game they feel great they have a bad one
they feel bad
the interesting thing that changed after
a little bit of time was
I started attaching my sense of
self-worth to the amount of suffering
that I went through in order to achieve
the outcome of the event so let's say
that the club night that we ran went
well or badly that would be the first
phase so if it went badly I was going to
feel bad but if it went well I would
always look at how much did I suffer in
contribution to this performance and if
it had come too easily I'd feel like I'd
cheated somehow or like like I owed
something it was like a Puritan work
ethic that just came through well I
would say that you know that sounds more
like that sounds like more like
internalized guilt okay if things are
going very well for you you know maybe
you don't deserve it maybe you're doing
better than other people in your life
that you that you care about you know
friends family loved ones you know maybe
you feel like you're getting getting
away with something right so so that's
that's actually a little different than
moral masochism because what you're what
you're describing it's not that you're
feeling you know Superior or virtuous or
especially righteous because you know
because you've worked so hard and
suffered so much it's I mean it it
sounds like you know things were doing
going pretty well and you were having
some some real successes right and and
then you have something it's kind of
closely related to Survivor guilt like
you see this in
uh
I mean you know uh most saliently in the
military in a combat veteran you know
their their whole you know their whole
platoon gets attacked you know every
most everybody you know gets killed you
know and a lucky one or two come home
and you think God they've got it made
she's like you know they there's a real
likelihood they may suffer the rest of
their lives because they have this guilt
it's like why did they deserve to die I
mean why did why did they deserve to
live
when people who are you know equally or
more deserving worthy and it was good to
human beings as they are you know when
they didn't live right so so some of us
have to like expiate or atone for our
guilt as a precondition for being able
to enjoy our successes some of this you
know it's you know you asked is this
just about you know pathology or these
disorders or or is this everyone it's
it's everyone and some of this is
um you know different societies and
religions have found ways of
institutionalizing you know ways of
handling this so you know like the the
confession and Catholicism is a kind of
an institutionally structured way of
dealing with guilt you can be successful
you know in your life and and you know
feel good about it but here we have this
very structured channeled place where
you can go and you know confess to your
your sins and your crimes real and
imagine and and be granted Absolution
and you know then you can carry on
I like that okay so next one false self
a false sense of identity borrowed from
others in place of exploring and
developing your own yeah
um you know of all of the ones uh I
wrote I wrote 16 you know 16 Concepts
that that's actually the one I was least
happy with how I described it
um I don't think I did Justice to it so
um
this goes back to early childhood and
infancy that under ideal circumstances
with you know sort of empathic loving
parents
who are not using a child you know to
sort of compensate for some you know
some felt deficiency of their own right
the parent is in the business
of helping helping the child to grow and
discover who they are right that's what
we'd ideally like like to see and it's a
sort of a process of you know growing up
is is becoming more fully ourselves but
but often something goes wrong right so
you have
um
you have a parent
you know typically a parent with some
narcissistic difficulties they don't
feel good about themselves in in some
important way
and they need the child to be something
to make them feel better about
themselves so rather than you know
rather than parenting as being about
um
you know we're discovering together with
this growing person
is becoming it becomes about the child
has to be something they have to do
something they have to behave a certain
way they have to be very good at
something they have to look a certain
way
and not for their own sake but but
basically for the parents ego and you
know when this starts very early on
it's like this way a child really never
has an opportunity to discover
their own thoughts their own feelings
their own experience their own you know
preferences likes and dislikes they end
up kind of having to mold themselves
into being something that that serves a
parent's needs and we call that a false
self as opposed to a true self and that
can last a lifetime
and you see it in I just imagine that
when you get to later later into
adulthood and people really have this
discordance they'll probably be almost
kind of two versions of themselves
battling inside of their mind
we you see it in entertainment a lot you
see celebrities a lot you know like
looking from the outside it's like my
God this person has everything you know
Fame wealth looks Talent right and
inside and there's something about it
that all feels empty and it's it's like
it's never enough no matter how much
success how much money how much Fame
accolades it's sort of never enough to
fill the emptiness inside and it's
because
and it's because
it's like they they have to be these
things yeah I'm not really explaining
very well I mean imagine
you know a child is very just physically
attractive and the parents take great
pleasure in that for their own purposes
they don't love the child's experiences
they don't feel loved because they're
them they feel loved because they look a
certain way and that does something for
the parents right well now they grow up
imagine they become a you know an actor
or a model or something like that I mean
it's like they end up living out you
know living out somebody else's needs
living out their parents needs
rather than discovering and living their
own right so they perpetually feel
unhappy and empty and then people look
from the outside and say you know I
don't get it this person has everything
but it's because they can't see this
discordance that's going on inside of
them
it's because they never had an
opportunity to
discover who they are and what's
meaningful to them what brings them
satisfaction and you know and meaning
you know independent of
serving a function for somebody else is
it so you is is it always
um parentally induced is there any other
way that a false sense can a false self
can come about
um huh good question I I think it starts
in early childhood with your primary
caretakers but then it you know then it
tends to continue elsewhere right it
begins that way and then it develops a
certain you know a certain momentum so
you know suppose a child feels you know
the parent that's but usually the child
has some gift or ability suppose they're
you know very bright and parents take
great pleasure in this but you know it's
like it's not that the child enjoys
being bright it's that they have to be
otherwise they feel like
you know they're not they're not really
loved they're not loved for themselves
right well now they go to school and
maybe they attract teachers attention
because they're you know particularly
bright right and and then it and then it
just just kind of um
you know it it kind of creates a sort of
vicious circle it feeds on itself right
you do more and more of the thing that
you get attention for that you get
positive attention for
but at the expense of you know
discovering what's actually meaningful
to you and at the expense of feeling
loved and worthy for your own right you
know versus some particular you know
gift or ability
transference responding to another
person as if they were someone from your
past for example punishing someone in
the present for wrongs someone else did
to you when you were growing up
that's the big one
so let's go back to we what I said at
the beginning we we form certain kinds
of
patterns of relational patterns ways of
relating to other people and we tend to
recreate these patterns for the rest of
our lives you know sometimes we're
better sometimes for worse but and the
patterns are formed in our earliest
attachments you know they begin with our
our parents and family siblings and so
on and they continue through other
people
um
and
you know the the patterns are in
invisible to us but the thing is
um our expectations of what happens in
relationships are you know are forged in
our earliest relationships
um so
we don't
see other people so much as you know who
they are in any any objective sense
we see them through the lens of our own
patterns our own experience our own
relationship patterns you know so I mean
let me make it a little more you know
clear you know in our earliest
relationships we learn you know how to
be with another person you know how to
respond when somebody is angry with us
how to make somebody like us how to you
know get attention you know what other
people find Charming what other people
find intolerable it's like we kind of
internalize these these rules of the
relational Road about you know how to
live and how to be in relationships with
other people I know you go out in the
world and you encounter new people who
you don't know and you apply the old
rules of the road for better or worse
right so so it's like our experience of
other people in the relationship is
always experienced through the lens the
the lenses that we bring with us now you
know this is the the sort of gradations
you know I I like that's always the case
we always bring who we are into a
relationship that you know ideally
there's some you know some relationship
some some some you know some I don't
know Synergy between what we're bringing
and being able to experience the other
person as they are when things go wrong
it's like we don't even see the other
person we just bring our own you know
our own assumptions and our own you know
desires and wants and needs and it's
like the other person is irrelevant it's
like they they get shoehorned you know
to fit into our patterns right so you
know imagine somebody who's grown up and
you know a family where they were
mistreated in some way or mistreated or
coerced they just they experience other
people as you know angry and hostile and
trying to control and coerce them now
they go into the world
and you know and bump up against all
kinds of people who do what they do but
everything is through the lens of their
feeling put upon they're feeling
mistreated and they tend to lash out at
the people and the the person getting
lashed out is like you know like like
what the hell what what did I do I mean
so this is the most important concept I
think in all of in all of psychology
um so the idea is we transfer right the
word is transference we transfer our
early patterns wishes desires fears
needs that were created in early
relationships we transfer them into
current relationships I imagine that
somebody that has more extreme
transference
will start to believe
we'll see more not Serendipity but Deja
Vu occurring because all of their
relationships they always end really
bitterly they're always people are
always this to me and people are always
that to me yes well is that the case or
is it good actually
you're seeing this is coloring whatever
they do well it's a little bit of both
but it's the lens through which you're
seeing that but if you then respond
accordingly you know if you think
somebody is being you know hostile or
controlling or coercive right and then
you know you respond to that you know
you you respond with hostility yourself
right and now there's a way we end up
creating we draw the other person we
draw the other person into our patterns
we end up recreating
um you know recreating the patterns that
we've brought to it let me give you like
a concrete example this comes up a lot
so one of the personality disorders is
paranoid personality sorry these are
people who go through the world with
with constant chronic suspicion they
think other people are out to do them
harm that's their default assumption and
it's like water to a fish it's not like
well I think that about this particular
person because here this unusual thing
happened it's like there's always
something in their mind that explains
why they think somebody else is you know
is out to hurt them
and
so they begin acting very you know
angrily and belligerently and become
controlling around other people you know
out of a desire to protect themselves
right well if you're on the other end if
you're on the receiving end of that it's
like who the hell wants to deal with
that person right so you know now you
don't include them you're not upfront
with them you don't share things with
them you watch your back you know like
you tend to get more controlling
yourself because you know the other
person's going to take advantage of you
if you don't right so someone with a
paranoid personality style there's a way
that they create a paranoid environment
for themselves right they make it come
true
[Music]
um
so so there's a way we we bring these
lenses you know from past relationships
we bring them with us into new
relationships
but the other people you know they're
they're involved it's an interaction
there's there's two people here right
the other people get kind of drawn into
like you know into the magnetic field of
uh you know of um it's like it's like
they get it's like they get
gravitationally pulled in to the other
person's distorted view of things and
now it's actually happening it it feels
to me like you have another concept that
might be very closely tied to this
projective identification projecting
unacknowledged feelings motives onto
someone else then behaving in ways that
provoke the very feelings you have
projected for example projecting rage
onto someone else and then treating them
so badly that they actually become
enraged
well that's a yeah that's that's the
most complicated one of all and in fact
that that is a very particular version
of transference
um and we're seeing a lot of it in
public life right now so so
let's start with the simpler instance
the simpler instance is just plain
projection plane projection is there's
something unacceptable you know
something I feel unacceptable in myself
you know my anger my hostility of my
sexual wishes whatever
unacceptable myself
I don't want to know it about myself I
defend against it I'm not these things
and the way I defend against it is I
project it onto someone else onto you
I'm not you know angry and toxic and you
know destructive and wanting to hurt
people you are right that's the
projection
um what makes it a projective
identification is the person takes it a
step further it's not just that I see
you as being angry and hostile when you
otherwise might not be at all it's that
I then proceed to treat you in ways that
uh you know that that actually evoke
those feelings in you in other words I
make the projection come true right so
if I see you as angry and hostile
and I then treat you so badly and do it
so relentlessly until you actually
become angry it's like now it's
confirmed right it's not defense it's
really true you know it wasn't a
projection that I saw he was angry and
hostile look at that you are angry and
hostile so right so projective
identification is getting rid of some
you know some feeling or motive that we
find is intolerable in ourselves
mistakenly imagining that that it
applies to somebody else and then
treating them in such a way
that you actually you know you actually
managed to
uh you have actually managed to create
the kinds of you know feelings and
attitudes that you projected to begin
with
could think of it as a kind of a
self-fulfilling prophecy precisely what
I had in my mind yeah and also
um it it ends up
justifying your own Viewpoint to
yourself right if you do provoke
somebody to become enraged or whatever
it might be when they do finally snap
and treat you in that manner it is a
reinforcement mechanism for your
prediction I knew it all along it's con
exactly it's confirmation right so you
know the way it it works it it goes hand
in hand with another defense but people
who do this tend to see the world in
very black and white terms so other
people are you know good or bad
caricatures you know their heroes or
their villains
splitting right that is splitting yes
um
so you know the projective
identification you decide that someone
or some group or some identity is bad
you know they're evil
and then you treat them as if that were
true as if it were a fact you treat them
like they are evil and you treat them so
badly you know that they finally react
against it and you know and then push
back and you know and you know become
angry and aggressive because they've got
no choice they've been pushed into it
they're getting you know they're getting
treated like a punching bag you know and
and you know and they put up with it you
know so long and finally they punch back
and say huh see that person is toxic I
knew you know I knew they wanted to
punch me it's kind of like that so going
on to splitting perceiving others in
black or white categories seeing them as
one-dimensional as purely good or purely
evil this is something that I see so
much online at the moment and I've
always wondered what's going on
psychologically that is causing people
to choose a lower resolution view of
other people I understand that it's
simpler to
throw people into categories of either
good or bad or evil or my team or their
team or whatever because the Nuance of I
disagree with this person on X but may
agree with them on y requires an awful
lot more mental effort well everything
you said is right but it goes much
deeper than that so
our understanding of early you know
early childhood development is um
laughs
let's see how do I we have a concept in
uh called object constancy so object
constancy so
um if you spend time with with little
children you see it that before a
certain developmental stage
if if something isn't like physically
present in front of them
the the child or the infant doesn't
really have the capacity to hold it in
mind so you know for example parents all
over the world play usually mothers and
children they play the peekaboo game and
and there's you know with the squeal you
know peekaboo and there's like squeals
of delight from the children and the
children never get tired of it you know
they play peekaboo forever but you know
why is it so exciting what's really
going on
um they just when the when the mother
you know covers her face peekaboo
up to a certain developmental level the
child actually doesn't have the you know
the mental equipment at that point you
say oh yeah she's still here she's just
you know behind her hands right right so
the child's experience is something like
she magically you know vanishes and
magically reappears and and the moment
the child
you know achieves what we call object
constancy which is the ability to
recognize that something still exists
whether we see it or not in front of us
right the moment that happens then the
game stops being fun it's just like oh
you know mommy's hiding her face right
right the magic of it is gone so if you
take that concept and you apply it to
people
you don't have a stable enduring sense
of you know
this is my mother this is my mother you
know in this setting this is my mother
when she's cuddling me this is my mother
when she's sculpting me or punishing me
right in the after in the absence of
object constancy it's like the child
keeps having these unrelated experiences
with different mothers we know it's the
same mother right but up until a certain
developmental point that the child
doesn't know right so so you can think
of it as a kind of Shifting Kaleidoscope
of mental representations of the other
person or the the self in relation to
the other person
and they're all separate it's like the
shifting Kaleidoscope of like fragmented
parts and pieces and with development
comes the ability to start to integrate
those different representations and you
recognize it's the same mother you know
the mother who accidentally poked me
with a diaper pin you know and made me
cry as the same mother who held me and
Cuddles me and feed me it's not two
different people it's one person right
so think of these these these you know
Snippets pieces of relationships as the
kind of the building blocks of of mental
life now when the building blocks start
getting integrated into what we call you
know a hull representation right a
three-dimensional representation of the
mother and it's the same mother right
the mother is angry at me as the same
mother who you know who loves me and and
Cuddles me it's the same person
you now have what we call a more
integrated representation of the person
right it encompasses you know both
things that we feel good about and
things we feel bad about
as the building blocks come together
they don't come together randomly they
come together along emotional lines so
the different images of the mother that
are positive that we feel good about
come together and create one image of a
good mother the you know images that we
feel you know bad about you know the
pain hurt aloneness anger whatever those
come together we have an image of a bad
mother right they're like two different
people the good mother and the bad
mother
and then with further development the
good and the bad get integrated and it's
like oh you know it's mother and
sometimes she's good and makes me feel
good and sometimes she's bad and makes
me feel bad but it's the same person and
I have all right so in a way the child
achieves ambivalence ambivalence means
you have you know you have multiple and
sometimes conflicting or contradictory
feelings toward the same person right so
I like this about you I don't like that
about you right that's that's
ambivalence that's a that's a very you
know nuanced three-dimensional view of
you
so when something goes horribly wrong in
development
um and often it's related to abuse or
neglect
that level of integration doesn't happen
and you experience the world in this you
know fragmented way where you know
people are good or bad I don't see
people in their in their complexity
and uh you know and you carry that
forward right it's like something that
was supposed to happen developmentally
never happened and you know what happens
is when the person gets upset
they completely lose the capacity to
recognize that somebody else is another
human being you know just like them with
good qualities and bad qualities and you
know that people are nuanced and
complicated and you know exist in Shades
of Gray that just you know that's the
Human Condition that's so I mean the
person loses the ability to perceive it
that way so that in such certain other
people are seen as you know all good all
virtuous Heroes you know and others are
seen as all bad as villains so the
person ends up seeing the world in this
very caricatured cartoon-like you know
cartoon-like way you know when there's
heroes and villains
and no three-dimensional whole people
and when you're on the receiving end of
it you know right because you know
you're just going about your life you
know interacting with them doing
whatever you do and all of a sudden you
know you're getting vilified in this
extreme way you're getting seen as
somebody it just has no relation to how
you experience yourself it's like where
did that come from
right well where it came from is this
this bad you know this bad
representation inside the other person
right they don't recognize it as a part
of themselves
has gotten projected onto you and now
you're the bad person and they can treat
you that way and you know and I honestly
think this this
goes a long way to explaining some of
the the worst aspects of the culture
wars because we we lose we lose the
ability to see other people
as complex three-dimensional human
beings we start seeing the world as you
know as caricatures of Good and Evil and
the good people are you know completely
right and virtuous and in the right and
what they want to do is you know with
what they want to do is the right way
and the people who become the bad object
uh you know they're evil and they should
be treated that way you have this other
tweet thread that I loved I think
splitting projection and projective
identification seem to all tie into this
severe personality problems find
camouflage no one thinks I'm a sadist or
I'm a malignant narcissist they find a
belief system or social group that
validates their most hateful destructive
impulses and construes them as virtues
the most toxic and hateful people in the
world are 100 convinced they fight for
what is true and right
yeah well think about it you know
nobody thinks we're very rare exceptions
nobody thinks I'm a bad person I'm cruel
and I'm vicious and I want to hurt
people and you know I I like
you know I like destroying things I like
doing damage I like causing other people
pain right I mean it's pretty hard to
live your life and think that about
yourself right now in fact there's
something inside the person they they do
want to they do want to do damage to
others they there is something in in
these people that's very cruel and very
destructive
but that's not their experience of
themselves right their experience of
them their experience is
all that that evil isn't inside of me
it's inside you you're the one who's
evil right so so there's the splitting
and the projection right the the
splitting
if the person were not splitting they'd
be like you know this is me and I have
some good qualities and God sometimes
I'm just an [ __ ] and you know
sometimes I'm just needlessly cruel but
you know I'm more than that too I'm also
kind and loving right we have this very
complex nuanced view of ourselves
ideally
when splitting happens we don't have
that I'm good you're bad you're cruel
you're violent you're destructive you're
a bad person
right so so that's the splitting
and the projection
if I see you as a bad person you know
who's harmful and destructive you know
and needs to be reigned in
now I feel fully Justified and you know
in in treating you horribly you know in
in abusing you mistreating you hounding
you out of a job you know canceling you
I can do anything to you because you're
evil and you deserve it there's no
limits on you know how there's no limits
to my cruelty
because in my mind it's not my cruelty
you're the cruel evil person and you
need to be held to account
right so and you treat somebody that way
long enough you know well they will
become enraged and they will want to
fight back right and like we were
talking about before that now confirms
my view you really are you know you
really are this evil violent person who
wants to you know who wants to do harm
right so we find a way to justify our
worst impulses
and imagine ourselves to be very good
and virtuous when we're doing that right
we're not being cruel we're fighting
evil the problem is even with this
understanding even knowing the fact that
most people see themselves not as evil
or bad or purposefully trying to do ill
stuff to everybody else when we see the
impact of what these people's actions do
it's very hard to find empathy for them
you're like why should I why should I
care why should I care that you have
this Litany of issues which is
contributing to the way that you're
behaving and that there's maybe even
some clinical diagnosis that could look
at this person is it toward the upper
end of this particular spectrum of of
disorders or a combination of spectrum
of disorders
you just think that person's a dick and
I need to respond to them in kind
and and that's the projective
identification right now you don't get
to respond to them the way you might
otherwise spontaneously you know want to
treat them right you're now responding
to the provocation they are turning you
into the worst version of yourself right
so the projection becomes true
I think this person is a dick I treat
them horribly and lo and behold they
start acting like a dick you know I was
right right so so the person engaged in
this it's a very primitive kind of
Defense because you know I mean it's
really saying here are these you know
things about me
you know my capacity for cruelty you
know my you know my pleasure in hurting
people by destructiveness we all have it
it's in all of us everybody has the
capacity for these things and it's
saying no no these don't don't belong to
me
you know this is not me this is you
and so it's a defense that that really
distorts our perception of the world and
our perception of other people it's it's
a costly defense because
um it really causes us to lose touch
with
who the other people are around us
what's the role that the group plays
here so you said they find a belief
system or social group that validates
their most hateful destructive impulses
and construse them as virtues yeah so so
some people get you know some people get
the goodness projected onto them and
they're you know and they're treated
wonderfully they're they're they're
heroic they're good people they're
virtuous they can be appreciated they
can be admired well those people start
thinking hey you're a great guy the
people that you're projecting the
Badness onto and mistreating they think
you're a horrible person so you've got
you know two two groups of people that
are having completely different
experiences of the same person right
depending on
depending on whether the good or bad is
being projected onto them
so you know usually
um
you know especially if you you spin it
in in sort of moral terms you know
they're bad and immoral and they need to
be stopped and we're good and we're
moral and we're gonna stop them because
we're fighting the good fight you know
if if you
um you know if you do that
then the people doing the most cruel and
toxic and destructive things you know
kind of find an in-group that shares
them on and says yes yes you know we're
on the side of good and right and virtue
repetition and enactment when something
we do not want to know or understand
about ourselves gets played out with
others over and over
yeah well that would be an example I
didn't think if something we don't want
to know about ourselves is just our
capacity for for cruelty and
destructiveness and you know we keep
making other people the villains I mean
not not because the other people are
inherently villains because we need to
see them that way and we keep reliving
this relationship over and over and over
again not just the damnedest thing
wherever I go in the world you know
there's just horrible vile evil people
that need to be stopped no matter where
no matter which social media side I go
on by God there here they are also and
there's no acknowledgment you know that
that the the hate and the cruelty and
the destructiveness comes from within
but that that's an extreme example we're
all involved in repetition and in
enactment so repetition is the idea
you know we have um
we all have all kinds of unresolved
conflicts uh that we sort of carry
within us this isn't good or bad or
pathological it just it's just human
nature you know and in one way or
another
we tend to repeat it over and over again
as we go through our lives and what
right so that would be that's called a
repetition
when we draw somebody else into playing
out that script with us we call it an
enactment because now there's two people
involved in in acting it out together
and actually
this is how the kind of therapy I
practice works
people come into therapy
and they begin repeating what they
repeat right in relationships in general
but now they're doing it in the therapy
relationship because that's a
relationship too and they draw the
therapist in to reenacting something
it's almost unaviable you get pulled
into enacting something and the
therapist does and what makes therapy
therapy good therapy and not just you
know one more relationship where the
same old thing happens
is in the rest of life you just continue
reenacting the pattern in therapy you
reenact the pattern but somebody
hopefully the therapist has the capacity
to step back and say basically
something's going on here what are we
doing let's think about this you know
did you notice you know did you notice
you know you seem to assume this or that
about me and you know and and treated me
on that basis you know when when uh
I don't know when I had to cancel when I
had to cancel our appointment because of
you know an emergency came up in my life
in your mind
it's because
I don't like you and I'm fed up with you
and I would rather not have you as a
patient I would rather you know I'd
rather be done with you
and you responded to me on that basis
the you know I I wonder if we can think
about
um that may be true
but I wonder if you can think of
other reasons why I might have had to
cancel the appointment right we're
trying to sort of expand the person's
capacity to think differently so that
the things they take for granted right
the things that I call like water to a
fish
suddenly become things that we can you
know call into question and reflect
about it's like oh like maybe you didn't
hey maybe you don't really hate me and
want to be rid of me with the patient
you know maybe you have a sick child at
home or you know forever right so we
take these patterns that we just reenact
you know kind of mindlessly throughout
our lives and we basically say look
there's a pattern going on here let's
really think about this how did this
came about what led up to it you know
how did you understand when I did thus
and so how did you understand it when
you responded you know thus and so right
so that what we're what we're really
doing is in the rest of life things
happen very automatically and rapidly
you know we go from point A to point B
and it just you know in our mind that's
just that's just the way it is what we
do in therapy is we slow things down and
say well between point a and point B A
lot has gone on there's all kinds of
thoughts and feelings and experiences
and memories and maybe it's not a
foregone conclusion that you know the
that a leads to B and that just you know
that's just a fact
maybe there's choices between point a
and point B maybe a you know maybe a
doesn't have to inevitably lead to point
B maybe there's more freedom there than
we realize
reaction formation masking underlying
feelings and attitudes by expressing
that opposite to an exaggerated degree
for example expressing exaggerated
approval and admiration towards someone
you secretly look down on yeah so it
it's a pretty straightforward defense
where we protect ourselves from knowing
something that we don't want to know
about ourselves
by experiencing the opposite of that
um
an example would be uh
imagine somebody who's just absolutely
fascinated drawn to pornography but but
that's completely unacceptable they
weren't raised in a you know they
weren't you know they weren't raised in
the community that has any place for
that that could possibly you know accept
it or understand it it's bad I say I'm
not the kind of person that's interested
in pornography in fact I hate I do test
pornography it needs to be you know
condemned right so imagine somebody like
that who then devotes himself to
becoming an anti-pornography Crusader
which requires constantly looking to
find pornography right so that you could
condemn it right that's a reaction
formation it's saying you know I'm not
I'm not interested in this I'm not drawn
to this I'm disgusted by it right so we
often you know we can mask a particular
feeling or attitude by substituting the
opposite the example I gave in the in
the thread that you uh that you read was
um
well what did I say again with that
expressing exaggerated approval and
admiration towards someone you secretly
so suppose you look down on someone you
know you you load them you think they're
inferior
but you're not the kind of person that
would ever look down on and think
somebody was inferior certainly not on
the basis of you know some identity
characteristic you just you know you're
just not that kind of person well you
know if if the impulse to look down on
them is you know is strong you need to
defend against it maybe you turn it into
the opposite but you know you valorize
and glorify them right and then you know
all of a sudden you know all of a sudden
the person could do no wrong in your
eyes when you scratch you know scratch
the surface of those attitudes though
you know sometimes you find quite the
opposite
um so this
performative empathy that is often being
maybe you become you know very
differential and worshipful to you know
to the group that you understand many
many parallels with the modern world at
the moment yes
see that that's the thing you know these
are Concepts that go back to the turn of
the you know the turn of the century the
turn of the 20th century I don't know
these are you know 100 plus year old
ideas
and people sometimes they get discussed
as if they were like these ancient
artifacts you know we don't we don't
have to deal with that anymore right
that's what I meant when I said we have
very uh cheap superficial kinds of
therapies now right these are these
ideas don't apply to us these are you
know things from the distant past like
no they're not they're here with us
every single day we're we're swimming
them all the time you know people people
may not know the words or the concepts
but we're living with them all the time
and it's not like this is some dated
outmoded thing that's not relevant to
day-to-day life it could not be more
relevant to our day-to-day life
displacement shifting feelings from one
person or situation to a different safer
one for example attacking someone who
cannot defend themselves in the place of
attacking someone who can retaliate yeah
you know so the classic example of that
is you know somebody feels badly treated
at work you know they're angry at their
boss they feel like their boss you know
their boss didn't you know did wrong by
them you know
I you know they'd like to shout at the
boss or punch the boss but of course you
can't do that you know maybe they come
home and kick the dog right that would
be a pure example of displacement so one
of the things that we you know we
understand in Psychology is that that
there's something about feelings that
they can be they can be shifted very
easily they can be redirected so that a
feeling that originates in one place can
be expressed in another place and that's
what that's what displacement is the
feeling is still there right whatever
you know what what whatever the feeling
is
but we're directing it at something else
something or someone else other than
where it really started that sounds
quite cowardly that seems like a a
cowardly approach to whatever's going on
rather than pushing back against the
person or the thing which is causing you
issue you go to something which is
more vulnerable
well it would be cowardly if it were a
conscious choice and we knew that that's
what we were doing but right the the
thing about you know all of these
defenses is they operate relatively
unconsciously while we're doing it we
think we're just dealing with reality we
kick the dog because the dog was being
bad you know I mean so I mean you know
when we start to talk about you know
cowardice that implies understanding and
choice yeah yeah and volition whereas if
this is operating outside of awareness
it's not clear that there's that much
Choice well that is where the
difficulty in
culpability comes from you know we like
to think that people are The Architects
of their own actions you know we we
definitely like to think that we are The
Architects of our own actions we like to
think that we don't want to feel like
we're at the mercy of our programming
and there's just some several hundred
thousand year old biological
predisposition just pulling the strings
above us that's definitely not something
that we want I mean you know maybe maybe
other people but certainly not us and
certainly not the people
so
it seems like a
very difficult situation to be able to
find the requisite
understanding and empathy for people who
do these things especially given most of
the stuff that we've gone through today
is really [ __ ] annoying like if
anybody did that it's so super super
irritating you know when people do it
every day there's nothing mysterious
about any of this we encounter this you
know we encounter this regularly
there is this sort of modern Bailey
thing as well with the pullback like
this is what I'm saying well that wasn't
what I was saying I actually went there
and then you get the response and then
somebody complains about the response
and then maybe they end up doing
something to somebody else because of
the response that you gave to them and I
can see that these all kind of I would
imagine not like comorbidities but co uh
yeah they're all inter complexly
interrelated yes yes and one will
Cascade down into others
this is the essence of it right I mean
this this traces all the way back to you
know
to Sigmund Freud and you know turn of
the century Vienna that
he you know I mean some of what he wrote
has stood the test of time some not so
much
but the fundamental breakthrough is we
don't fully know ourselves we don't
fully know our hearts and Minds there's
such a thing as unconscious mental life
and that is the essence of it that has
stood the test of time and now we have
research you know they couldn't do it in
Freud's day we have research and
experimental psychology we have research
in cognitive Neuroscience we know that
it's true we don't have one brain right
the brain didn't you know evolve all at
once the brain is composed of multiple
structures that came about you know at
different points in the evolution of the
species and they're not in harmony right
the conflict meaning contradictory
contradictory experiences about about
things contradictory motives is is
rooted in the architecture of the brain
itself right we know that now so so
Freud said in his own time
he said that his Insight was the third
of three great blows to human dignity
and the first blow was Copernicus said
we are not at the center of the universe
we're just one more planet among you
know many others right man is not at the
center of the universe the second blow
came from Darwin who said you know we
are not separate and apart from the
Animal Kingdom we are part of the animal
kingdom we are biological no we are
animals we are biological beings with
all of the evolutionary Heritage that
goes with that and the third the third
grade was the one that you know that
that Freud himself identified and it is
we're not masters of our own house
we think that we're doing things because
we've decided to and it's volitional and
it's conscious and you know what we
consciously think about something
is all there is
whereas in fact you know mental
Consciousness is like the tip of the
iceberg of mental life so we're doing
all sorts of things all the time for
reasons we don't fully understand
the other the other contribution was you
know it doesn't have to stay that way to
that extent right that in fact we can
come to know ourselves more fully and
that's what this kind of therapy is
about that you know but fundamentally
you know fundamentally there are things
about ourselves and why we do what we do
that you know aren't fully under our
control
what do you wish more people knew if you
could try and give a single Insight that
you think would have the most impact
to the well-being of people's
psychological health
would it be that would it be the fact
that we are not completely in control
and that there are mechanisms that are
working below the surface or is there
something else there's mechanisms
working below the surface but
you know many of them you know can be
brought to the surface that you know I
mean we get into the question of Free
Will which you know is a philosophical
question that's not going to have an
answer you know I I can't speak to you
know do we do we or do we not have free
will what I can say with some confidence
is there are things that we can do to
develop a Freer will
Freer than before and and that might
make all the difference and as far as
what I'd like people you know to know
right so people are getting sold a bill
of goods about what Psychotherapy is you
know take depression for example that's
the most you know probably the most
common diagnosis that you know that you
see in in you know medical records
um
there's a kind of this cultural myth
that depression is like a disease you
know depression you have depression
well for most people most of the time
depression is is in effect not a cause
it's the thing that's wrong isn't your
depression right the thing that's wrong
is something going on psychologically
that's causing distress and we
experience distress in the form of
depression right so good therapy as I
understand it is
let's find out
what's underlying this depression
so that maybe it doesn't have to
continue
versus you know you have depression
depression is the problem here's
techniques and interventions we use for
depression you know we'll change your
thoughts we'll try it's medication
without any concept of wait a minute
there's more to this than meets the eye
you know we're more than our symptoms
we're more than our conscious thoughts
and our Behavior there's more to us than
that and before we're getting you know
in such a hurry to get rid of a symptom
which generally doesn't work get rid of
the depression
maybe it's there for a reason
maybe we can understand the reason right
and out of that understanding comes the
freedom to do things differently so that
we don't have to keep experiencing the
same kind of distress
how can people choose or work out
whether they are currently with a
therapist that is useful and effective
for them what is a way that a patient or
somebody that is going through therapy
would be able to judge the usefulness of
the therapeutic relationship with the
particular clinician they're working
with yeah so so there's different I
should you know I should put this in
context I mean there's different kinds
of therapy for different purposes the
kind of therapy that I'm you know that I
practice and I talk about is called
psychoanalytic or psychodynamic therapy
which is oriented around you know coming
to no aspects of our experience that
that are not fully known and that
requires a relationship it happens in a
relationship so remember I said you come
into the therapy relationship you bring
your lenses your templates from your
past relationships and you start
reliving them reenacting them in therapy
right that's where the information is so
once you understand that
what it means is if you're in meaningful
therapy that's aimed at inside and
understanding
it means you're going to be talking
about the relationship in the room with
the therapist so here's like a
two-question test for are you getting
meaningful for Psychotherapy it comes
from a friend and colleague of mine
Michael Carson I can't I can't take
credit for it
think of a time that you were upset with
your therapist
did you tell them yes or no
right if the answer is yes it might be
in meaningful therapy
if the answer is no
you're not in meaningful therapy why
because the work is
we count on the patient to [ __ ] up the
therapy relationship in the same kinds
of ways that they [ __ ] up their other
relationships so we have to talk about
we have to pay attention to what goes on
in the Psychotherapy relationship it is
and it's a very intimate relationship
we're talking about very very personal
private emotionally charged things it is
impossible to have that kind of
relationship sustained over time where
you do not get upset with the other
person it just doesn't happen they're
going to say so they're going to piss
you off they're going to misunderstand
you they're going to say the wrong thing
they're going to get it wrong they're
going to say something that sounds cold
or callous it's going to happen right
what makes therapy what makes this kind
of therapy meaningful
is you can tell the therapist you're
upset that's the thing you know step one
now now a lot of people are very
inhibited about
you know
asserting themselves about saying to
another person like you know I don't
like this and this pissed me off you
know some people have our time doing it
so so I want to add a qualification
think about a time you were upset with
the therapist did you tell them
or is the work in therapy moving in a
direction where you're going to be
increasingly likely to tell them
increasingly able to tell them in the
future right so did you tell them if you
told them you might be in meaningful
therapy and then part two when you told
them
should they respond with interest and
curiosity
or did they get defensive right so a
competent therapist you know you say to
your therapist you know you're kind of
an [ __ ] about blah blah blah whatever
competent therapist doesn't explain
themselves and say oh no I didn't mean
that you misunderstood I meant to do
this when they don't rush in with an
apology or a competent therapist
basically says oh
tell me more about that I'd like to
understand this better right so the
things that are going on in the relation
in the therapy relationship between the
two of you there are sources of friction
become things to to think about and talk
about and reflect on together right so
when you say we count on the patient to
[ __ ] up the therapy relationship the way
they [ __ ] up their other relationships
by talking about it thinking about it
reflecting on it together
we go through a process of you know
unfucking it right making sense of it
clarifying it finding a way to have a
relationship that works for two people
not just for one person at the other's
expense right and once we know how to
have a relationship that works for two
people right that then you know that
then that understanding that way of
being and thinking you know then carries
over into other other life relationships
right so we can have a more intimate
relationship with our you know our
partner a husband or a wife you know we
can have more meaningful and closer
friendships we can you know collaborate
more effectively with you know
co-workers people at work right our
capacity for you know communication and
and connection with other people and
intimacy with other people increases
so let's come full circle and bring it
back to the example of depression
there's a lot of ways to get to
depression right the depression is like
um
depression is like the psychological
equivalent of fever
so what's fever fever is a non-specific
response to an enormous range of
underlying you know physically
physiological difficulties you know
anything from from the common cold to
Ebola right so you know when a physician
takes your temperature and you have
fever that's that's not that's not the
end of the diagnostic process that's the
beginning right so it's non-specific
depression is a non-specific response to
an enormous range of underlying
psychological difficulties so we know
somebody's depressed we haven't
diagnosed the problem we've you know
we've described you know the most
surface you know surface manifestation
of a problem now we've got to figure out
what's going on what's making them
depressed so
you know suppose something consistently
goes wrong in your relationships you
never get your needs met other people
never respond to you the way you'd
really like you never feel cared for you
never feel like you matter in
relationships
is that going to lead to depression you
know hell yes you are going to sooner or
later that is going to show off as
depression what do we treat do we treat
your depression
or do we look at what's going on in the
relationships that's getting in the way
of getting what you need from them
well that's what we do we look at what's
going on in the relationships that's
getting in the way starting with what's
going on in the therapy relationship
itself and that understanding and
Carries over into our other
relationships
okay I imagine that there must be a
difficulty
if the client patient
um
is very concerned with politeness maybe
or with
um not being seen by the therapist as
making too much of a fuss or or
misbehaving in some way because what you
end up with is is a very sort of um
sheltered thin veil that kind of
obscures some of the stuff that you're
looking to do it's so such an
interesting Dynamic to say that what
you're actively looking for as a
therapist is for the patient to [ __ ] up
the relationship between you and them in
the same way that they do with everybody
else yeah and we don't even have to look
for it it just happens what we have to
do is be able to recognize it and create
a space together where it becomes
possible to think about it and discuss
it right they are going to [ __ ] up the
relationship in whatever ways they're
going to and actually the example you
gave may be the most common right so uh
we see this a lot that there are people
who are
either relatively unaware of their own
emotional needs they don't they don't
don't let themselves don't let
themselves know what they need or want
or you know they know
but they have a lot of difficulty
speaking up and saying so they tend to
go together actually
so if you're that kind of person and
it's really common I mean I really want
you know your listeners to understand
these are not you know obscure you know
disorders this is just woven into the
fabric of day-to-day life for lots of us
and if you're the kind of person
you know who has difficulty recognizing
or expressing you know your needs from
other people your experience of Life
your experience of relationships is
you don't get your needs met
then a lot of things follow from that
you know you're likely to feel you know
depressed hopeless deflated you know
nothing ever works out for me I never
get what I really want you know I met
this guy I thought he was wonderful this
guy was going to be different but he
doesn't care about what I need either
right and then maybe the person gets
increasingly resentful because they're
putting all this effort and energy into
this relationship and their experiences
nothing is coming back well it's a
one-way Street
you say you know what's wrong like oh my
husband doesn't he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about my feelings he thinks only about
himself
maybe you get the husband you know you
get the husband in you might hear a very
different take the husband be like I do
everything I can to try to please her
and make her happy and it's like you
know nothing I do is good enough why is
it not good enough because she never
said what she wanted he's not a mind
reader right so the idea is that that
Dynamic is going to get recreated in the
therapy relationship so right all kinds
of things are going to come up day in
and day out where the the person the
patient is unhappy about something in
the therapy or wants something that
they're not getting and they don't speak
up about it that's the problem right
there in the therapy relationship now
they start to get you know resentful or
sullen
and the thing that makes it therapy is
you don't just relive the pattern with
another person you just reenact it with
somebody new and the therapist says but
something is going on here you know
there seems to be something something
that you want from me that you're not
getting
no no you're great you know you know
you're a really good therapist you know
everything is good it's like well you
know I know and I I mean I appreciate
that you're
you know I appreciate that you're being
so nice about it
but it seems like we're only hearing
from one part of you it seems like
perhaps there's another part of you that
that has something else to say that
we're not getting to hear from
right so you know repeatedly we we just
keep inviting into the room what's being
left out
um
I mean a pretty sort of trivial normal
example suppose therapists five minutes
late for the for the session
a lot of patients who are you know sort
of agreeable nice people
will say oh no the therapist I'm sorry I
was late I blah blah blah something ran
over time oh no it's okay and you know
you're always here on time you know
always I knew there must have been a
reason right they'll they'll sort of you
know let it slide
and when we say in therapy is you know
basically you know all of that's true
you know yes I am always here but you
know I notice
I notice we're not hearing neither of us
are hearing
you know
wow what
you know what it was like for you when
you were here and you know I wasn't here
when you expected me
you know it's just like
we're not hearing from that part of you
no you've taken very good care of me
yeah I I know that's that's true that
perhaps there's something else that's
also true if we could make some room for
that
well I I did think for a moment maybe
you just forgot about my appointment
I hate now you just now we've just uh
you know got a little crack in the door
about you know there's a whole world of
meaning behind that that we wouldn't
otherwise hear from hear about you know
unless we pursued it
chances are the person who does that is
probably you know suppose they're you
know suppose they're
I don't know happily or unhappily
married or they're in a marriage and
they're dissatisfied with something do
you think that kind of interaction Oh no
just fine do you think that doesn't
happen every single day in some way or
other right maybe we don't get to hear
about the things that are just fine
so right that's that's kind of the
parallel between what goes on in the
therapy relationship and what goes on in
real life relationships outside of the
therapy
I really like that Insight Jonathan
let's bring it home I've really really
enjoyed this I love your insights here
uh why should people go if they want to
keep up to date with the stuff you do
um well I'm on Twitter Jonathan at
Jonathan shedler on Twitter uh I've got
a web page online it's my name and
people can find articles and blogs and
papers that I've written all right
Jonathan I appreciate you very much
thank you thank you what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]